PEGI 12  monsters will align once more  Andrea's under threat are we gonna stand  around here all night or are we gonna  take action huh I'm game if you are  let's hit the road partner I got this  little beauty bag so now I'm pretty much  on stubble  [Music]  I'm not a child  so stop treating me like one  [Music]  doesn't feel safe at all  [Applause]  say hello to my enormous friend  we're in this together if we face Morgan  we face him as one you do make it ever  so easy  [Music]  trying to show you and that's all I can  do  come on laddie we have a date with  destiny  [Music]  both luminarie we swear to protect you  while we live none shall defeat you yep  we're all in this together sure is what  you've got let's do this  lead on darling  [Music]